there's a few breaking moments in life
where like whatever your stuff is and
whatever you believe it's suddenly like
you just for whatever reason like
there's some like existential thing that
you you get confronted with it at some
point and either either you cower in
that moment or you confront it and I
just think that everyone that confronts
it it doesn't mean you'll win the first
time around like you might learn some
really bad lesson and by the way that's
not to say look James d'amour did get
laid off it you might be laid off
fighting lose friends all of those
things except the real question is do
you want to live sort of bowing down all
the time to some like unknown enemy or
do you want to say what you believe and
then at least have a chance to live on
your terms and I think that that's what
a lot of people are realizing right now
[Music]
I'm Bridget Pharisee and I'm here with
Dave Rubin with the don't burn this book
book club doing Chapter two hi Dave
hello Bridget
Chapter two we thought this would be a
good one for you in light of the
Pharisee evolution a fetish yes it has
been an evolution I think what you know
right out of the gates in this chapter
you talk about years of self-deception
you mentioned when people maybe have
been deceiving themselves for years
what were you deceiving yourself about
for all those years yeah well I think
one of the things that's happening right
now is that a lot of people are
realizing either that they've deceived
themselves or maybe that they've viewed
the world a little bit incorrectly and
they're trying to piece together a new
world and actually even though I wrote
this before coronavirus especially right
now I think a lot of people are going oh
there's a new world on the horizon maybe
everything that I believed in before
isn't quite exactly right maybe I have
to think about a new way of thinking
about things I referenced in chapter one
that it's time to come out and I talked
about you know coming out of the closet
which usually people apply to sexuality
and that right now there's a lot of
politically closeted people that just
aren't saying what they think and it
probably goes both ways mostly I'm
talking about it from like a lefty to a
more centrist or a right thing but I'm
sure there's a version of it that's the
other way that you grew up very
conservative and you start thinking more
liberal thoughts and and you could be
closeted that way or any which way so I
was look I was closeted about my
sexuality first so I just know what that
thing is that sort of insidious
inability to deal with reality as it is
and just once you can't accept a part of
yourself whether that's your sexuality
or just something that you innately
believe or or feel or want to fight for
or any version of that once you don't do
that and you start hiding that it
cascades into just like a gajillion
other problems yeah how do you tell
people who might suffer real-life
consequences
to come out because unlike sexuality now
thank goodness mote you can't lose your
job for instance if you come out but
some people you talk about it in this
chapter James de Mar might lose their
jobs and they have then how does
somebody how do you how do you go about
coming out or do you yeah what do you
know super interesting it's so
interesting because when I go to college
campuses I get some version of this a
lot where young people will be like you
know I want to tell my friends that I'm
a libertarian or I want to tell them
that I'm a conservative or something I
once was giving a talk a couple months
ago in Atlanta and a young guy came up
to me at the bar after the talk and he
sat down and he was he happened to be
young black guy and he sat down and
first he told me that he was gay and
then it took him it took him another
like 20 minutes of chatting like the gay
thing just he was just like I'm gay like
whatever and then it took him like
another 20 minutes of talking to
basically admit that he was a
conservative and he actually told me he
told me as a young guy I'm talking like
probably nineteen twenty years old he
said that coming out to his parents
about his conservative beliefs was way
harder than coming out as gay as crazy
as that sounds as crazy as that sounds
and I've heard a lot of that nightmare
story but what's also interesting when I
mentioned people like James d'amour and
Lindsay Shepard at wilfred laurier who
is a TA who literally all she did was
show her class a Jordan Peterson video
and then was taken into the diversity
and inclusion office and reprimanded and
and many other people that have survived
the mob one way or another you know you
know a ton of these people it's like
once you once you sort of get in the
pool this is a Douglas Mari line about
you know if you if you get in the pool
you might find out the water's not cold
I think generally what happens is you
know a guy like James d'amour who's you
know by all by anyone's estimation he
was extremely good and probably still as
an extremely good engineer he had just
got a promotion like two months before
at Google they send him to this
diversity training class and then they
asked them we
would love your feedback and I'm
guessing most of those people didn't
give any feedback he actually did it
like they said here's homework the poor
guy
poor guy whatever he heat goes ahead and
does it and then not only loses his job
because of it but then we see what
happens with everybody the the Machine
just comes after them you know all the
hit pieces suddenly he's racist even
though he didn't talk about race of
course he hates women and he hates gays
and the rest of it and you know I
mentioned this in the book but it was
the only time ever in all the shows that
I've ever done where James d'amour came
in here he was so nervous and so quiet
and shy and so somebody that didn't he
didn't want any of this I had to spend
about an hour with him just just kind of
getting him to open up and then
fortunately you know how it is sometimes
the camera goes on and people just
magically kind of become something and
he did he was able to like turn it on
10% but you know he's still pretty quiet
and shine the rest of it but the point
of it is is that if you embrace it you
will get to the other side like I I have
no doubt that James d'amour right now
does not regret what he did sure maybe
he'd have a better I don't know what his
job is right now I know he's still in
the in the field and he's has an
engineering job but I have no doubt it's
not at Google I have no doubt that
because he stood up for himself he's
proud that he did it I know for a fact
Lindsey Shepard is proud that she did it
I know that Jordan Peterson who stood up
against Bill
c16 in Canada I know he's proud so all
the people that I've seen survived it's
like every single one of them is better
even though yet some friends are gonna
turn on you some people are gonna say
some horrible things and most likely
HuffPo ain't gonna be nice to you either
yeah to say the least you say to and in
fact if you miss the boat there's a
chance you'll end up stranded and where
will they be stranded well I had a
literal place although you could be
stranded on an island I suppose but I
think part of it is that you know you
only get a couple chances in life to
really like stand up for what you
believe like we all kind of we all kind
of walk through life and there's
assertive day to day routine and we're
in a like a particularly weird aspect of
it right now with coronavirus where we
sort of like it's
does the weekend anymore and is
Wednesday the same as Sunday so it's a
little strange right now but yeah nobody
knows anymore right but like I think
there's there's a few breaking moments
in life where like whatever your stuff
is and whatever you believe it's
suddenly like you just for whatever
reason like there's some like
existential thing that you you get
confronted with it at some point
and either either you cower in that
moment or you confront it and I just
think that everyone that confronts it it
doesn't mean you'll win the first time
around like you might learn some really
bad lesson and by the way that's not to
say look James d'amour did get laid off
it you might be laid off you Viton lose
friends all of those things except the
real question is do you want to live
sort of bowing down all the time to some
like unknown enemy or do you want to say
what you believe and then at least have
a chance to live on your terms and I
think that that's what a lot of people
are realizing right now it's like that
thing that's been quieting all of us
that makes all of us secretly be like oh
I don't want to be called a racist or a
bigot even though I'm not those things
it's like it only gets power by us and
that never confronting it and I think
more and more people finally are
starting to confront it how do you know
you're not deceiving yourself now or how
do you how does one guard against
self-deception it's tough right because
you could end up going and I think about
this a lot because look I'm not I'm not
stupid or naive like I've been embraced
now by people that I used to think were
the bad guys right like the the set of
people on the right that now I find to
be quite tolerant and open and all that
I'm not saying they're all perfect for
sure but what but I am sort of welcomed
into a new home right now and maybe they
see me and they go oh well here's this
nice guy and he's open-minded and he
treats us well so we can kind of use him
along the way too I don't think that's
really what's happening with the people
that I've truly sort of embraced in this
space let's say you know Glenn Beck or
Shapiro or Prager or some of these other
guys but I think the key of what you're
asking really is like how do you make
sure once you think one thing that one
you when you find something else that
you start thinking how do you make sure
you don't fall in the same trap again
and then just end up doing it you know
three years later and then
just keep like you know jumping
hopscotching through life I think the
key is that you got to start doing some
work and that's what a lot of the rest
of the book is about which is you really
gotta start knowing your stuff so look
you're the one who coined the famous
factory-settings'
line and I and I love it so much because
we're born with these factory settings
that culture and education and movies
and everything kind of teaches us where
it's sort of like Democrat good
Republican bad left these are nice
conservatives are cold you know
Republicans like or Democrats like peace
like some really crazy stuff and and
when you break out of that they'll
suddenly be a whole new world and you'll
go oh that stuff isn't true but it
doesn't mean that everything that you're
gonna get on the other side is true
either so I think it's then on you I
mean a lot of this book is is why I want
people to think for themselves it's on
you not to just then go oh there's a
whole new group of people here and
they've got new thoughts there must have
been right about everything and I was
wrong about everything like it's not
like that I don't think I was wrong
about everything before and I've somehow
come to the truth now I think I got some
I think I got some key things wrong and
I had a lot a lot of my good liberal
ethos was always there and it's still
it's still here and I think actually the
Conservatives that I disagree with they
actually appreciate an honest liberal
debating with them right somebody made a
really great point that I'll never
forget and they said it's not what
you're saying it's what you're not
saying when I was saying everybody's
accusing me of being a crystal or
whatever and so what are you not saying
is there anything you're not saying are
there are you censoring yourself in any
way now wow I I don't think so I mean if
I am or even if you think I am I I would
love to hear it I I think I have been as
honest with every one of my opinions as
humanly possible
you know I lay out look in this book
nobody if you're just like a complete
ideologue on each side you're you're a
pure Democrat or lefty or you're a pure
Republican or conservative whatever your
there's stuff to be pissed in for every
pissed off of me for all of it I mean
the abortion chapter I literally I
literally
and it by saying now that you all hate
me let's move on so it's like you know
abortion is the one for the right that
they just view as like this cannot be
touched like it's pro-life pro-life but
I make a pro-choice argument here you
know like I talked about being married
to a man in this book you know they know
I'm against the death penalty like this
is stuff for them that's really tough
and yet at the same side at the same
time obviously I'm hitting things that
the left's not happy about when I when I
do a pretty swift blow against identity
politics and a bunch of other stuff so I
don't think there's anything else that
like people don't know about me or that
well I'm certainly not intentionally
hiding anything I would say that way but
but also what happens is as you start
embracing it you will go oh there was
some stuff I didn't know so for example
when people say to me well have you
shifted on anything or is it just that
the left went bananas it's like well
actually I do think the left went
bananas and they have a real issue with
free speech and cancel culture and all
that but I'm fully up front like
economically I've absolutely shifted to
the right I want you Bridget to keep as
much of your money as possible I want to
take more money from the government so
they can't just do stuff and it's your
money in the first place and I'm pretty
sure that whatever you learn you know a
better thing to do with it then they
know what to do with it and by the way
I'm pretty happy that right now with
with everything going on with Coronas
messed up as it is I think a lot of
people are waking up to that all these
people that are struggling financially
it's like yeah you should have had more
of your money in the first place
I think that a lot of people in liberal
enclaves in particular just because of
the nature of the crackdowns
are seem a little bit more draconian
places like la our mayor in particular
is very hardcore do you think I mean how
many neighbors did you spy on today
because you never paid Speier if you if
you you know you see your neighbor and
oh my god he was brushing his hair four
feet away from somebody else you can get
some seriously cold hard cash it's just
so crazy
you mentioned identity politics and do
you see I see the right and use identity
politics do you see any of that on their
side and them in the right wing at all
um I think there's probably some version
of it there but I think it's muted in
many ways because basically the write
has a bigger belief in individual right
so where where they may use it for like
political tactics or like some subtle
language thing I do think that if you
look if you're a libertarian or a
conservative you pretty much believe in
individual rights like I don't know I
don't know certainly any like public
intellectual on the right that doesn't
believe that everyone in America should
be treated equally under the law
like I'm not saying that that person
doesn't exist I I have yet to meet that
person is there a Twitter troll on the
right that believes you know something
else of course I think the bigger danger
and why so many people have trouble
embracing the wake up call is that they
see something wrong with the left you
know because they think there's a sort
of idea like you're on the Left you're
just nice and open and you like gay
people and you like Muslims and you're
open and fun and whatever and it's
really like it's really just like a
scary thing to go whoa like I might be
one of those people or something that's
not these people I think that really is
what it is so is there an identity
politics on the right well look yeah I
guess on the fringe part of the right
like is there some sort of white
identitarian thing I mean well of course
there is like is there a KKK like there
is I don't know how many people are
really part of it but I don't think it
has any sort of like real like juice
behind it and also oddly and this is
like the you know the political fishhook
that kind of comes around or the
horseshoes so that everything ends up
the same it's like if you're a
right-wing what we would say is a
right-wing you know white supremacist
well that means you're a collectivist
and actually if you're a collectivist
you're really more on the left meaning
you believe in groups when people talk
about far-right like something like
technically actually I should talk to
Michael malleus about this at some time
but like someone like Michael malice is
more what I would say far-right if we're
doing this correctly
meaning that far right meaning he's for
far ultimate individual liberty at the
expense of the state that would strike
me as more technically correct for
far-right rather than an identity Rhian
who believes in collectivism that
really goes the other way but that's why
the right-left thing we always talk
about this the right-left thing is just
so out of whack right now it is and it
kind of leads me into my next question
you say the left is no longer liberal
and where do people who identify with
progressive values but perhaps not crazy
leftist authoritarianism go yeah I mean
go you know I know a lot of people who
can't just hold their nose and vote for
Trump for instance and I know that the
binary is kind of a myth but at the end
of the day you have to vote for someone
or not vote at all but yeah it's a tough
one because yes the the binary is it's a
myth except it's reality yeah right it's
a myth in that it's a myth like it
shouldn't be it's like an imaginary
thing that sort of morphed into reality
so what I would say for those people and
by the way obviously a huge chunk of
this book is written for those people
because I was one of those people look
you can I think you have to you have a
choice your choice is either somehow
stay within the left liberal bubble and
see if you can reclaim it from within
which by the way I tried to do for a
long time you can watch a lot of videos
of mine from 2015-2016 I'm going guys
I'm a lefty I'm a liberal what are we
doing I'm screaming I'm talking to all
these lefties who are experiencing the
same thing and then at some point I just
felt it was an unwinnable battle and I
think a lot of people do realize that
that something has taken over on the
left that is just decimating the whole
thing and look even just right now with
with Biden it's like they chose Biden or
the party chose by it and and we can
talk about all the mental stuff with him
or whatever else but it's like there's
no sense that that these people believe
anything together
AOC and Biden don't believe anything
together so my feeling is there's just
right now there's just not much left
however what I do see on the right is
there are plenty of more libertarian
minded people say like a Glenn Beck and
then there's more traditionally
conservative people say like a Ben
Shapiro and I'm just picking people out
of our crew but I could give you
politicians in this vein as well so
you'd have like more
libertarians like Rand Paul and then
more traditional conservatives like Ted
Cruz I see that as fertile ground for
for something good so I always want the
conservatives to know by the way guys
I'm not trying to trick you into being
pro-choice I'm really not I just want
something broadly on the right to make a
little space for the exact people that
you're talking about and by the way I
think they're doing a pretty good job of
it because I think they're they are
being kind of open-minded like when was
the last time you know someone on the
right like really tried to like you know
mob you for for saying something it's
it's weird yeah my my experience has
been that they're more willing to at
least have the conversation and I think
that's where the two parties are just so
look so differently right now is that
you if you speak out against the tribe
you might be kicked out of if it's if
you're you might be kicked out of Magha
for instance but you'll dos still space
for you and the conservative party
whereas if you push back against the
left and you kind of just get kicked out
so I feel like there's a huge population
of people who might be interested in
your book but there's where do they go
there's a variable I know well where do
we go where do we go the answer is the
answer is we build it like the answer is
like we blaze the trail that that truly
is the answer look everything's changing
right now you look I wrote this I
finished this book in July and it's out
now at the end of April but the but the
point is that the ideas in here are
timeless and it's like the left-right
republican-democrat thing that's not
gonna that's not timeless that's just
that's just a construct politically that
you know can stay for you know a certain
period of time and then moves on there
we used to have the Whig Party you know
to be nice duh but he's so like nothing
stays forever and if maybe the
progressives or the you know maybe they
really decide to be the Socialists and
the Democrats can be more of the sort of
corporatist wing and maybe ultimately
the Republicans will say here's our
traditional party and here's a more
libertarian party or something like that
but more than anything else I don't
think you have to belong to a party I
think you have to go alright here are
ten things that I care about and you
know six of them
Jupp with these guys and four match up
with these guys and I'll just kind of
figure it out as I'm going to that
voting booth yep and you and I know we
all become kind of political
abstractions and almost cartoons online
and we're hard on the lefties what good
do you still see remaining and that and
the this is my last question really what
good do you see remaining in the left or
what's left of the left
if if by the left we mean sort of what
modern leftism has become so like the
Burnie AOC kind of identity politics
government is everything left then
frankly I don't think there's anything
left I don't think there's any good
ideas left it doesn't mean there aren't
good people there I think there's people
with some bad ideas that have been
confused because of the factory settings
and some other stuff so I think it's our
job right like someone like you that
also is on your own political evolution
and you did you you were exactly there
was the reason I wanted you to do this
chapter was because you did embrace your
your wake up calling you're very upfront
that like it's a work in progress and
I'm not going to be on a team right now
and all that kind of stuff so if if
that's what we mean by the modern left
then there really is nothing left at
least for me if you mean what the last
few disaffected liberals like you know
the Jedi after order 66 who are strata
across the galaxy well then what do they
have to do they have to I think they
have to talk to the guys that they
thought were the Sith who may not be the
set that word Star Wars reference to
bring it home I had to cut like 80 Star
Wars references in this book so I
thought I could get one in there thank
you for asking me to interview you and
good luck with the book I love I love it
it speaks to me obviously my wakening is
definitely it's it's been you made so
many people feel sane and I am one of
them I am one of the people that during
the confusion because what I think
happens like you said as you start
feeling like you're going crazy and if
there had been no internet and no Dave
Rubin and all of the people you were
speaking with at that time I think I
probably would have thought I was losing
my mind and maybe lasted more than more
than now listen now you're doing that
for other people so I guess the
adventure continues yes
well thank you thank you Bridget if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and
again notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell